Bugün sizlerle biraz ottan çöpten
Sonrasında da
kakamızdan bahsedeceğim Ve bunları da
sonrasında birleştireceğim
sosyolog olduğum için bir sosyal bilimci
olduğum için bir yandan da bu farklı
gibi görünen süreçler arasındaki
ilişkiye dikkatinizi çekmek istiyorum
bir yandan da yine bu konuşmada Aslında
gündeme getirmek istediğim ve sizi
motive etmek istediğim konu şu
biyoçeşitlilik ve bugün çok önemli
konulardan bir tanesi dünyanın
Sürdürülebilir bir açısından bir o
çeşitliliğe sahip çıkmak genetik
çeşitliliğe sahip çıkmak aynı zamanda
çok kültürlülüğe yani çok kimlikliliğe
çok dilliliğe çok dinliliğe sahip
çıkmakla son derece yakından bağlantılı
bir yandan da bu mesajı vermek istiyorum
şimdi
keyiflerimizde aslında
yeşilliklerin serpildiği yeşerdiği çok
canlandığı bir mevsimden geçiyoruz
Aslında ottan kökten konuşmak için tam
da zamanı diyebilirim Çünkü biliyorsunuz
Bahar Ayları türlü türlü bitkinin
canlandığı bir mevsim ve biz bunların ne
kadarını biliyoruz bir annelerimizle
kıyasladığımızda bizden büyüklerle
kıyaslandığında çok azının nasıl
koktuğunu biliyoruz hangi yemekte
kullanıldıksa ne lezzet verir nasıl Bir
kokusu vardır vesaire falan giderek bu
bilginin azaldığı bir dönemden
geçiyormuş ki birçok bilim insanı Bu
döneme yaşadığımız ve bu duruma
insanların bitkilere karşı yeşilliklere
karşı azalan ilgisine bitki körlüğü
kavramıyla bir şekilde açıklıyorlar bunu
bu şekilde
tanımlıyorlar Maalesef bitti körlüğü
yüzünden bugün ee işte ebegümeci'den Ee
nasıl diyelim size hindi Bağlara Ondan
sonra farklı bak yeşilliklerim
serpildiği bir dönemde bunları
tanıyamıyoruz bu bireysel bir mesele
değil çok toplumsal bir mesele ve bir
takım arkasında Çok ciddi bir takım
sosyal süreçleri barındırıyor nereden
çıkartıyor oğlum bunu mesela Biz bugün o
konuştan bahsettiğimiz zaman genetik
çeşitliliğin azalmasından bahsettiğimiz
zaman genellikle hayvanlar gelir
aklımıza mesela Herkes bilir işte
Pandalar yok oluyor kar leoparları yok
oluyor işte kutup ayıları yok oluyor Bir
tane bitkinin ismini söyleyebilir
misiniz bana yok olmakta olan çok azdır
herhalde Bunları bilen ama bugün
dünyadaki toplam bitkiyi bitkilerin
%50'sinden fazlası yok olma tehlikesi
ile karşı karşıya Yani aslında çok ciddi
bir sorunla bir karşı karşıyayız ve bu
sorunun da Elbette ki dünya açısından
son derece önemli bir takım problemlerle
küresel ısınmadan gıda sorunla gıda
güvenliği sorunda yeni mikroplara karşı
çareleri üretmek konusunda bir sürü
çoğunlukla da olumsuz indikasyonları
olabilir gelecekte Bunlar devam ettiği
takdirde Neden peki bitki körlüğü Bu
kadar yaygın biraz daha yine gıda
üzerinden devam edecek olursak bitmek
çok açıklama yapmak mümkün ama daha
ziyade gıda üzerinden
ilerleyelim son derece
hepimiz dünya genelinde İnsanlar
genellikle artık şehirler de yaşıyorlar
şehirlerde
betonlaşmış fiziksel çevreler bizimle
beraber ve dolayısıyla çok az
yaşamalarını kalmış durumda bir yandan
da olsa bile ki buna rağmen o kadar
Aslında dirençler ki Ee Yeşiller
harbiden bir asfaltında bile çıkıp
karşımıza çıkabiliyorlar ama çok uyaran
var Biz gezdikçe şehirde ee bütün bu
uyaranlar bizim o yeşili görmemizi de
muhtemelen engelliyor ve ama bir yandan
da baktığımız zaman bugün mesela
botanyaya karşı Yani bilgi bitki
bilimine karşı olan ilgi de bütün bu
bahsettiğimiz süreçlerle alakalı olarak
azalıyor mesela İngiltere'de artık
insanlar bitki bilimi okumak istemiyor
hiç kalmamış öğrencisi olan bölümlerde
yavaş yavaş kapanmaya başlıyor Bu bunun
Ark
asındaki mesele diyebilirsiniz ki
Bitkiler hayvanlar gibi değil yani hani
su katsızlar bize Bir tehlike
oluşturmuyorlar Dolayısıyla öyle çok
fazla dikkatimizi çekmemesi de normal
ama bu tür açıklamalar son derece
evrimsel açıklamalar psikolojik
açıklamalar ve mesele bu kadar bireysele
sıkıştırılacak bir mesele değil çok daha
fazla toplumsal boyutu var burada da ne
var gıda üzerinden yaklaştığımız zaman
öyle bir dünyada yaşıyoruz ki artık
yediği Biz içtiğimiz çoğu şey başka
yerlerden geliyor bugün mesela Süper
markete gittiğiniz zaman aldığımız
kahveler kahve çekirdekleri dünyanın
başka yerinden geliyor kilometrelerce
millerce yolladı
geliyor ya tam buzluğa düşünün yani
yediğimiz içtiğimiz pek çok şey
yaşadığımız yerden başka yerlerde
üretiliyor ve ondan sonra biz bunu
sofralarımıza tüketiyoruz giderek
tarlayla Ee sofralar arasında ki mesafe
azalmış durumda aynı zamanda son derece
küreselleşen bir gıda pazarından bir
tarımsal bahsediyoruz Dolayısıyla Bütün
bunlar Biz de aslında Sebze ile olan
meyve ile yeşille olan ilişkimizi sadece
Süpermarket raflarıyla mağazalarla
sınırlı hale getirmiş durumda maalesef
Dolayısıyla mesela son dönemlerde Belki
sizin de dikkatinizi çekmiştik son
birkaç yıllık bir Google Lion
göreceksiniz Ondan sonra ıspanak
vakaları var Türkiye'de Neden insanlar
ıspanak yiyor Ondan sonra da
zehirleniyor böyle bazı şehirlerde
ortaya çıkıyor mesela Karadeniz'de falan
geçen seneler çok olmuş bu zehirlenmeler
ne ile alakası var Hemen aklınıza ilk
gelecek şey şu olabilir ya işte çok
kimyasal kullanılıyor Oradaki şeyleri
öğretmek için zararlı otları böcekleri
öldürmek için kalıntısı var bunu iyi
temizlemek lazım tabii ki bu bir unsur
ama başka bir unsur daha var aslında
ıspanak diğer yeşillikler gibi başka
daha zararlı yeşillikler ve birlikte
yetişiyor ve onlara temizlemek gerekiyor
ve bir zamanlar Muhtemelen bu temizlik
işini biz daha iyi biliyorduk Şimdi
artık biz mesela Hatta oturduğunu
tanımıyoruz bilm ve ondan sonra da o da
karışınca yemekte pişince bu sefer bizi
zehirliyor Yani diyeceğim odur ki o
kadar azaldı yeşillere karşı olan
ilgimiz bunların temizlenmesi bile bir
sorun olmaya başladı Türkiye gibi gölge
tarımın daha canlı olduğu yerlerde bile
ve Bu gördüğünüz bir harita tarım
bakanlığı yapmış böyle bir araştırma ve
zararlı otların ne kadar yaygın olduğunu
göster ama zararlı Otlar kadar Elbette
Karadeniz'de önemli ama maalesef dediğim
gibi bitki körlüğü bizim bunları ee
bütün bu otları yararlandığımızı Eee
zararlısıyla bizim tanımamızı engelliyor
size Bu meselenin sadece Türkiye ile
alakalı olmadığını dünyayla alakalı bir
şey olduğunu gösteren başka bir küçük
örnek utan anlatmak istiyorum belki
tanıyanınız vardır bu eee fotoğrafta
gördüğünüz kişiyi Ee
dünyanın en önemli en çok bilinen Belki
de şeflerinden bir tanesi bu arada belki
bilindik şefi en meşhur şefi bu
kopenhag'daki
Roma restoranının ki yıllardan beri
dünyanın en böyle hani aklınıza
gelebilecek böyle bir kavram vardır ya
Böyle çok iyi paralara Ondan sonra işte
lüks yemekler yediğiniz vesaire falan
bunun adını yeniden koyan adam diye
biliniyor ve insanlar yıllarda yıllar
öncesinden buradan rezervasyon
yaptırıyor ancak öyle Yemek yiyebiliyor
falan mesela Geçtiğimiz aylarda Dediler
ki biz bunu kapatıyoruz bunu söyledi ve
onun yerine burayı bir okul haline
getireceğiz falan dedi böyle gastronomi
Dünyası sallandı bütün dünyadan ne
oluyor nereye gidiyor falan diye yaptığı
şey şu Aslında Eskiden meselesi işte
havyar Ondan sonra ne bileyim triplerle
falan anılan bir şeydi yani nadir
bulunan bir takım ürünlerle
özdeşleştirilen bir mutfaktı artık Öyle
ki yaşadığımız dünyada bu Yeşiller
azaldığı için yeşil değerini tanıdığı
azaldığı için ama bir yandan da Yeşiller
Hani düşündüğün olan besin değeri çok
yüksek düşündüğünüz zaman onunla çok
lezzetli şeyler işte bunlar üzerinden
bir zamanlar çok sıradan insanların
topladığı bildiği bir yöntem giderek
daha lüksleşen bir hale geldi ve Örneğin
önemli sözcülerinden bir tanesi oldu
dolayısıyla Bu enteresan ve göreceksiniz
Bunları bilmek için de bu yeşillikleri
bilmek aynı zamanda yerel bilgi ile çok
alakalı Bu da bizi Aslında o çok
kültürlülükten bahsettim ya genetik
çeşitliliğe sahip çıkmak için gerekli
diye bize o konuya getiriyor Nereden
geldin bakın Burada neler ettin
Japonya'daki Ee bir belgesel ile ilgili
gitmiş Oradaki yerelden bir insandan
bilgi alıyor Şimdi bu çok çok önemli bu
bilgiyi ancak neyle alabilirsiniz yerel
dilleri bilen insanlar tarafından
alabilirsiniz ve günümüzdeki en önemli
şeylerden sorunlardan bir tanesi de
yerel diller azalıyor yok olma
tehlikesiyle karşı karşıya dünyanın pek
çok yerinde değilse o kadar önemli ki
dille Biz dünyayı isimlendiriyoruz
kategorize ediyoruz neredeyse yeniden
şekillendiriyoruz Hüzün kelimesinin
olmadığı bir dilde hüzünlenmeniz mesela
mümkün değil değil mi hüzünlenemezsiniz
Çünkü öyle bir kelime yoktur dolayısıyla
her yeni dil demek bize yeni imkanlar
Demek yeni olasılıklar göstermek demek
tek bir dilde bunu göremezsiniz ama
farklı diller size dünyanın bir türlü
sorunlarına karşı yine alternatifler
üretir yeni bakış açıları geliştirmenize
yeni perspektifler geliştirmenize
yardımcı olur ama diller ne oluyor
birtakım büyük hegemonik dillerin
gölgesinde mesela İngilizce gibi ya da
devlet politikalarıyla ırkçı
eğilimlerden beslenen Ondan sonra
baskıcı politikalarda giderek yerel
dillerleçeler aksanlar yavaş yavaş
kayboluyor Bu da neyi getiriyor
beraberinde yerel bilginin ve
dolayısıyla yaya otlara dahi bitkilere
daha iyi birçok şeyle beraber kaybını da
beraberinde getiriyor Dolayısıyla
birleşmiş millet bunun farkında bile
demeyelim onlar farkında Çünkü dünyaya
bakıyorlar büyük Pencereden bakıyorlar
ve diyorlar ki ya çok önemli bir riskle
karşı karşıyayız Bu sadece genetik
diller kayboluyor buna sahip çıkalım
2022'de başlamışlar 2032'ye kadar bu 10
yılı yerli diller 10 yılı ilan etmişler
Dolayısıyla hakikaten bahsettiğimiz şey
çok çok önemli buradan geleceğim nokta
şu; Buradan da yavaş yavaş kaka
meselesine gireceğiz daha tip bir
dilimiyle monokültürel yapılar kurutuyor
ama çok kültürlü oluşumlar
zenginleştiriyor çevresel maliyetleri
çok yüksek mesela monokültürel tarımın
işte daha fazla yakıt kullanıyorsunuz
daha fazla kimyasal kullanıyorsunuz
ekolojik maliyeti yüksek sosyal maliyeti
yüksek herkes dayanamıyor Bunlar küçük
üreticiler eğleniyor ama çok kültürlü
yaptılar beraberinde huzuru getiriyor
iyiliği getiriyor refahı çoğaltıyor
Çünkü insanlar huzurlu oluyor düşmanı
olmuyor onlar birbirlerine daha töler bu
iş yerlerinde de bu böyle oluyor
yaratıcılığı
kışkırttığı için daha iyi iş yerleri
ortaya çıkıyor firmalar mutlu oluyor
Daha Ee huzurlu daha refaha sahibi daha
tatlı topluluklar Böylece
oluşturulabiliyor şimdi bunları nereden
biliyorum gene gıdalar üzerinden
konuşalım Bugün dünyanın çok önemli bir
kısmı giderek endüstri yaşayan giderek
daha fazla sayıda şehirde yaşayan insan
aynı şeylerle besleniyor ve bu yüzden de
giderek diyetler homojen homojenleşmeye
başladı ve bu da beraberinde herkes
pirinç yiyor herkes buğday yiyor herkes
soya fasulyesi ile bir şekilde
besleniyor ve bunun neticesinde de
diyetlerin aynı yaştığı homojenleştiği
bir dönemden geçiyoruz ve baktığımız
zaman yediklerimizin içtiklerimizin
dünya çapında aydınlatması ile beraber
vücudumuzdaki mikrobiya çeşitlilik ciddi
derecede azalmış vaziyette ve
dolayısıyla Tam da bu dönemde Aslında
biyologlar Doktorlar bize neyi
anlatıyorlar diyorlar ki bağırsaklar
bizim ikinci Beynimiz bir burada
Beynimiz var bir de daha aşağıda bir
beynimiz var Çünkü bu bağırsaklarımızın
sağlığı aynı zamanda ruhsal sağlığımız
aynı zamanda fiziksel sağlığımızı işte
hastalıklara karşı direncimizi vesaire
etkiliyor ve dolayısıyla
bağırsaklarımızın sağlığıyla buradaki
mikrobiyata çeşitliliği ile çok yakından
alakalı bunun kaybı demek bizim daha az
sağlıksız olmamız demek Ve bu bu tür
şeyler yani homojenleşme beraberinde
mikrobiyotanında azalmasını getiriyor
şimdi bu çok ciddi bir tehdit Neden
Çünkü
Mikroplar yani bakterısıyla mantarıyla
virüsüyle mikroskopik canlılar sadece
Zararlı değil aynı zamanda çok
yararlılar yani vücudumuz için yararlar
hem de habitattaki aslında oluşumları
Neyi beraberinde getiriyor Mesela bugün
bilim insanları mikropları kullanarak
kimyasal gübrelerin yerine daha organik
gübreler üzerinde Çalışıyorlar ya da
bazı bilim adamları mantarları
kullanarak Diyorlar ki biz plastikleri
öldürebiliriz parçalayabiliriz
dolayısıyla sürdükle gelebilirliğin
anahtarlarından bir tanesi mantarlara
sahip çıkmaktır diyorlar Dolayısıyla hem
bedenimiz için hem de Habitat için
mikroplara iyi mikroplara sahip çıkmak
yararlı mikroplara sahip çıkmak çok çok
önemli bu sürdürülebilirliğin çok önemli
koşullarından bir tanesi Şimdi böyle bir
durumda maalesef bizim yedi iyi bir
içtiklerimiz de azalan mikrobaya
çeşitliliğini telafi edebilmek için ne
yapıyor bilim insanları biliyor musunuz
başka dünyalarda dünyanın farklı
yerlerinden kaka örneklerini topluyorlar
Bu gördüğünüz bir mikrop biyoloji
mikrobiyota Bankası projesi İsviçre'de
Üniversitesinde bilim adamlarının başını
çektiği bir şey ve bakteri
çeşitliliğindeki kitlesel yok oluş
tehdidine karşı bu riske karşı sağlıklı
insanlardan kakalarını topluyorlar ve
burada belirli süreçlerden geçirdikten
sonra da donduruyorlar belki de İleride
Bugün hiç bilmediğimiz bir takım
mikroplara çare bulabilmek için bu
mikropları kullanacaklar yani zararlı
Mikroplar geçerli bulmak için yarar
kodları kullanacaklar ve bu kadardan bir
şey çıkacak Ondan sonra neden oralardan
oluyorlar Çünkü diğer yerlerde yaşayan
insanların diyetleri o kadar da homojen
değildi daha fazla daha az şeker
yiyorlar makarna yiyorlar pirinç
yiyorlar margarin yiyorlar ve bunun
neticesinde Belki daha fazla lifli
yiyecek tüketiyorlar ve daha mikrobiyoto
açısından çok daha farklı çok daha
zengin bir şeyleri var organizmalar var
buradan yararlanmak için bu da başka bir
proje bu daha açık bir proje açık
kaynaklı bir proje'den görüyorsunuz bir
bilim insanı gitmiş Sena geldi ki
köylülerle onların yaşam tarzları
üzerine veri toplamaya çalışıyor ki bu
velilerle bu şeyi sağlayabilsin bu
zenginliği sağlayabilsin bunun da derdi
gene aynı şekilde bu bir çeşit değil
kaka Bankası oluşturabilmek bir gayta
Bankası oluşturabilmek ve çok
Uluslararası bir ekip burada Aslında
yeni zelanda'dan tanzanya'ya İspanya'ya
Nijerya'ya ilk sürü dilimci bilim insanı
Ondan sonra Bu proje üzerine çalışıyor
ve Bu proje vasıtasıyla şu ana kadar 65
bin insana
mikrobiyata ve transplantasyonu yapılmış
yani sağlıklı gaital sahibi insanlardan
alınmış sağlıklı gayta bağırsak
hastalığı olan insanlara transfer
edilmiş bu yolla insanlara sağlık
verilmiş 65 bin insan bundan fekal
mikrobiyota transpar transportasyonu
yoluyla tedavi edilmiş Bugün bir
Amerika'da 2 milyon insan huzursuz
bağırsak sendromundan müzdarip
Dolayısıyla bütün bu çalışmaların
oradaki ve bu huzursuz bağırsak sendromu
hem fiziksel olarak hem de ruhsal olarak
sizi çok hırpalıyor eminim Türkiye'de de
bunun Ee gayet yüksektir dolayısıyla çok
çok önemli bir durumdan bahsediyoruz
şimdi
bununla turla geçireceğim konuşmam bunun
halatı çok önemli bir antropolog
antropolog ama onu çok da şey nedir
doğal bilimcilerde Mühendisler de çok
okumuştuk çok farklı
seyirciye izlemiş bir şey diyor ki
modernlik kendisini doğa ve kültür
ayrımı üzerine inşa etti bu yanlış bir
ayrımdı o yüzden de baktığımız zaman
birisi aslında hiçbir zaman modern
olmadık diyor yani Bunlar ikisi
birbirinden ayrılacak durumlar değil
Doğa ve kültür birbiriyle son derece
ayağa kalkalı Ama bir yandan bu Doğa
kültür ayrımı aynı zamanda bilimde
şekillendirmişti o bilimciler kendi
laboratuvarlarında ondan sonra
biyologlar kendi mikropları çalışmışlar
virüsleri çalışmışlar vesaire falan
Ondan sonra sosyal bilimcilerde kendi
odalarında Bunlar birbiriyle çok fazla
konuşmamışlar Dolayısıyla Çok
kültürlülük bir tarafta sosyal
bilimciler tarafından biraz Savcı
şeylerle işin içerisine girmiş öbür
tarafta da biyologlar bunlarla hiç
ilgilenmemişler Çünkü onların derdi yok
çeşitli değil Biz ne zaman ki aslında
birbirimizin
kakasına muhtaç hale geldik ve ne zaman
ki aslında hiç hayatımızda görmediğim
zaman sonunda yaşayan bir yerlinin
kaybettiği değil bizi dertlendi hale
geldi O zaman bu ilişkide daha kolay
kurabiliyor mesela sanki Kim bilir belki
bundan sonrası Bütün bunlardan ders
aldığımız çok farklı bir gelecek olur
Çok çok teşekkürler Sağ olun